The fundamental story of genesis is something like this.
Yeah,
and it's perhaps the most brilliant contribution of Judeo Christian thought to
world history.
It's,
it's total impact is virtually in calculable.
The idea is this,
that chaos can be conceptualized as something that has an essentially feminine
aspect as a matrix and a matrix is a structure from which other structures
emerge and the story of genesis makes the hypothesis that logos,
which is the word of God,
a phenomenon associated with speech and communication and logic,
logos,
logic,
rationality,
courage,
exploration,
all combined into a single entity or trait logos.
The combination of logos and chaos is what brings order into being.
That's what the story in genesis means.
It's not a empirical description of the origin of objects.
It's a phenomenological description of the origin of experience.
The idea of being that without the piercing glance of whatever consciousness is,
whatever the background of experience is,
the matrix chaos cannot be conceptualized as real.
It takes the interplay between the feminine principle chaos and the masculine
principle logos in order to produce being
now thoughts of substantial importance when you give some consideration to the
fact that immediately in genesis,
after the establishment of livable order,
the day of the Yahuah identifies as the individual human being with logos,
right made in God's image.
That's the essential characteristic of the human being.
And what that means is that the logos that operates in human beings,
which is this capacity to make order out of chaos,
is identical to the principal that gives rise to the cosmos from a mythological
perspective.
So it partakes of the day.
Eddie,
in a very direct sense in so far as being itself is dependent on its operation.
Okay?
Now it's still possible to claim,
given that perspective that a story with that sort of structure is superstitious
and then it doesn't bear any relationship to what actually constitutes reality.
But you have to understand that that story old as it is,
it's predicated on older stories and it's on the ground that those older stories
established that our entire concept of natural rights rests.
So if you believe that natural rights have an existence that's more than merely
arbitrary,
the reason you believe that is because they're predicate.
Those rights are predicated on the ideas that are expressed in these myths.